Ok so the MCU is filled with hundreds
and hundreds of amazing moments.
It's a franchise that truly deserves it's
legendary status and it's difficult to not
marvel at all it's achievements which as
of now are unmatched by any other studio.
Picking the moment that embodies
all that it is is very difficult
but there's one scene that forever stands
out in my mind as being absolutely perfect.
But why does it work so well
and why is it that the moment
somehow gets better after multiple watches.
Well throughout this video we're gonna be breaking
down exactly what makes this scene what it is,
as well as the storytelling behind it that just
makes everything about this a complete knock out.
Now if you love the scene I'd massively
appreciate the thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe for videos
like this each and every week in which
we examine the best parts of cinema
and discuss what makes them great.
If you're new here then this is the Heavy Spoilers
show, I'm your host Paul, aka your friendly
neighbourhood spoiler-man now lets get into why
this scene in Avengers Infinity War is Perfect.
Ok so Thor arriving on Wakanda to save the heroes
in their most desperate moment works on a number
of levels not only because of what happens
after it but also because of what comes before.
Throughout the MCU Thor was always a hero to me
that was way too over confident in his abilities.
In fact when we first meet him
this great character flaw is the
thing that gets him cast out of Asgard
and his first Solo movie is about him
proving that he's worthy of being the
king that his father wants him to be.
Now for as self assured as he is,
when we look back at the series,
Thor is also the person that has lost the most.
Before the events of him journeying to
Wakanda not only did he lose his mother,
he also lost his father, sister, brother....well
adopted brother, home, best friend and half of
all his people after Thanos' attack on his ship.
He's easily been on the most
devastating arc in the entire series
but this loss also gave him a false perception
of himself and what fate had decreed for him.
In Infinity War he even says that he's
only alive because Fate wills it so.
Because he'd lost so much and yet always come out
on top, he himself believes that the odds will
always be in his favour and even when he looks
like he's done that he'll bounce back. This again
plays into his character flaw and self belief
which we'll touch upon more later on in the video.
Now this line about fate plays massively into
how well the movie is crafted and why it luls
us into a false sense of security so that the rug
is pulled from under our feet come the final act.
What Infinity War does so well and
why the snap feels so devastating
is because the movie tricks us into
believing that the Avengers will win.
There's the aforementioned fate bit but
beyond that there's several lines of
dialogue and motifs that lead us down the
path to thinking that Thanos is done for.
After surviving the onslaught Thor sets out
on a quest to get Stormbreaker a mythical
weapon of great power. If we look at cinametic
conventions, most movies in the genre involve the
hero going out on a quest to get a macguffin
that will help them to defeat the villain.
We're even told that Stormbreaker is a
weapon which is the Thanos killing kind
so Thor going through the journey that
he does in which he gains it at the end
makes us believe that he now has
the power to stop the Mad Titan.
The movie also uses our
expectations to make us think
that we know exactly the
way that it's going to go.
In the franchise we've already seen the Avengers
team up and defeat several villains and Thor
arriving on Wakanda perfectly mimics the
scene from their first team up movie.
When we play them side by side
we can see that the same stances,
way that the camera is used to
portray movement and the music
are all deliberately chosen to lure
us into a false sense of security.
-
It's masterful filmaking and makes
the twist a complete gut punch
as due to all this build up we were sure
that the good guys were going to win.
Now why this scene also works incredibly
well is immediate the build up to it.
Our heroes on Earth are facing insurmountable
odds as the forces of Thanos swamp them and it
seems like all is lost. That is until the Bifrost
shoots down with a bass sound that would crack
your subwoofer and Stormbreaker flies out of it.
Within seconds the forces of Thanos are completely
decimated and when it returns to Thor's hand we
see the hero once more standing there triumphant.
Throughout the film Thor has
painted a sorry picture of himself
and he's very much been a character that's
defeated and down on his luck. However his
return here shows that the character we know
and love is back and he's ready to take Thanos.
-
Now why this works so well is because throughout
the film Thor has been going about things away
from Thanos. Rather than travelling to
Nowhere to take him on with The Guardians
he travelled to nidivallir
in order to get Stormbreaker.
I wouldn't necessarily call it cowardly
but he wasn't really rushing to battle
and up until this point in the film the character
hasn't had the action scenes that the others have.
He's been a shadow of his former
self, almost wallowing in self pity
and on the verge of Bully Maguire
asking him if he's gonna cry now.
However, here he's a complete opposite to
that, rather than skirting around the edges
he's running head first to his opponents
and completely wiping them in the process.
It's difficult to not get swept up in this
moment and because of this scene you can't wait
until Thor finally beats the villain and rights
the wrongs of all that have been done to him.
There is no way he can lose.
-
However, calling back to our earlier
point it's Thor's great character
flaw that is the reason why he does
and why he also dooms the universe.
In the finale after Thanos has collected all of
the Infinity Stones, we see Stormbreaker rushing
towards Thanos but rather than hitting
him in the head, it goes into his chest.
Thor has the opportunity to kill him but rather
than delivering a killing stroke he prefers to
gloat and rub it in Thanos' face that he won.
This over confidence and need to boast is the
thing that has always been his downfall and just
as we've seen before he fails because of it.
A moment that should be his greatest
triumph is now his greatest failing
and we watch in Endgame as he has to wrestle
with the fact that him taking this action
is what destroys not only half of all life in
the universe but also his belief in himself.
That is exactly why his arrival
on Wakanda is so perfect.
Beyond just being a cool entrance, that
saves his friends from death,it has a
number of layers to it that perfectly show the
good points and bad points of Thor's character.
Thor riding confidently into battle
believing that fate wills him to win
is precisely why he ends up losing in the end
and the scene is masterful in it's story telling.
Not only does it perfectly recapture the
elements from earlier in the franchise
but it also uses them to make us believe
that the film is going to go a certain way.
Us seeing the self assured, confident Thor
here makes our confidence rise as well
as we as an audience believe that the
heroes are gonna come through in the end.
However this high is what also makes the low
of the snap even more devastating and the
movie perfectly uses this moment to prop up
it's heroes so that they can fall even more.
Thor standing here confidently is a
complete juxtaposition to how we catch
them in the final scenes and whereas
he props himself up tall and proud,
cap slumps on the ground over the
visions corpse, knowing that all is lost.
The dynamics of the film are
complete opposite ends to each other
and the snap only feels so crushing to
us because it follows on from this scene
in which we were celebrating the
return of one of the best Avengers.
We watch as the hero goes on an arc
of being defeated, to rising up,
only to be crushed again by the final twist
and that is why this moment is so perfect.
It captures the character as
he believes he's bounced back
which makes it all the more devastating
when we see him lose. The music is perfect,
the timing of the scene is perfect and
the fact that it bases itself heavily
on both the good and bad in Thor's
character is what makes it astounding.
It also brings in several elements from earlier
in the franchise and just gets you so hyped for
the climax of the film that it's difficult not
to get swept up in it every time you watch it.
Thor arriving on Wakanda is one of my
favorite scenes in any comic book and
I think it's gonna be a while
before the MCU tops this in my eyes.
I'm still blown away by it to this
day and that is why it's perfect.
Now obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the moment so make sure you
comment below and let me know.
We're running a competition right now
and giving away 3 MCU box sets on the
30th Of August. All you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is like the video,
make sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode. We pick the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now so
message me @heavySpoilers if that's you.
If you want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of the What
If Trailer which will be linked
on screen now. We break down the
entire thing so it's definitely worth
checking out if you wanna know more.
With that out the way thank you
for sitting through the video,
I’ve been Paul and I’ll see
you next time. Take care, Peace